hello
and a huge congratulations on the movie
i'm
not just saying it because i'm talking
to you guys but i was absolutely
delighted by this movie so
geraldine i wanted to start with you
because your comedic sensibilities are
always on point but you really did blow
me away in this movie so i am wondering
when you're on set how do you know that
you
perfectly nailed a comedic beat who do
you look to
first do you feel it yourself do you
look at natalie do you look at your
co-star who do you turn to
whoa that's tough i think i think i feel
it myself but it's very rare that i'm
like
yeah did great i feel like i'm always
leaving the same thing like
um so but i think
when when it when i feel it it feels
really good
i've gotten really obsessed with asking
this question because i
always find it mighty amusing but what
do you guys notice
when natalie is really loving what you
do
what does she do behind the monitor that
signals to you that you are
nailing that tape sometimes i feel like
i can see her in my periphery like
with her headphones on looking at the
monitor like this when she's like
hunched over and has her face in her
hands that's when i know
that that she's giggling 100
um i also know the two of you have very
different uh
acting backgrounds here i mean for both
of you
is there any new technique that you
picked up from the other that you can
now take with you to future projects
100 i've been talking a lot today about
learning a lot of stuff from geraldine
but i think
in particular it was two things one
thing kind of letting down my guard a
little bit more
and secondly going with the flow
especially if the cast the director and
the set call for it
just kind of letting loosen and having
the ability to watch the scene
unfold in a slightly different way so
uh then that necessarily might be
scripted so a lot of improv and stuff
like that was a great learning for me
when we were in rehearsal deka had
like gone through the script and made
all these tabs and like
noted every single scene like what what
like there was just such detail
in his preparation and i remember being
like maybe i should do that
you did your homework i respect that
yeah uh
daker are you really that uncomfortable
with karaoke
and dancing oh yeah oh yeah definitely
yeah i am know you're a good actor but
like
that body language in those scenes it
spoke to me because i have the same
problem
oh great i mean that's this is fantastic
we get along really well i
um yeah i'm just not i don't know i'm
not wired that way so it obviously
worked well
in this scene but i think it was a good
thing for me to break down the walls
because there might be a scene one day
when it's like
dude you have to act like you are into
it
so i think that was important for me to
have that broken down a little bit i
think the main thing is like just
learning to
go okay i can kind of make a fool of
myself because i feel like i have a
category where i'm like
i can make a fool of myself in this
range and then once i'm
outside that i'm outside my comfort zone
and it was really important to
confront that i think was there kind of
like a rip the band-aid
off moment in that respect on this set
where you made
you made a fool of yourself at one point
in the shooting schedule and then it was
kind of smooth sailing in that
department after
i think so but i think for me i was just
leading towards the
the karaoke thing yeah that was
definitely a big thing for me
geraldine do you ever get like
self-conscious like that
no i think the only time i'm
self-conscious is if it has to be like
sexy or something that's where i'm like
don't know how to do that
but uh in terms of making a fool of
myself it's where i
love to be what about the uh
i mean without spoiling anything of
course but the the big emotional
beat towards the end because i i think
that's another thing in this movie that
you absolutely nailed was that kind of a
new thing to jump into for you here
um i think you know i've done
i i have i feel like there's always even
in comedies there's always that
that moment where i think the it drops
into
into a serious scene or like you know
even in blockers i feel like there was a
scene
with john cena where we were both being
genuine and sincere and so i feel like
that's kind of that's always there so i
i knew that was coming speaking of john
cena and you've worked with
so many incredible people over the years
and you know
here here you're the lead of the movie
you're number one on the call sheet
who would you say that you learned the
most from not even necessarily
just like acting on set and leading a
movie but also just how
the lead can kind of set the tone on set
two hmm
um i mean really everyone that i've
worked with that is like
super seasoned and i mean daniel
radcliffe comes to mind he's such a
class act and make
and he works so hard and is so
considerate and same with hugh jackman
like they just
these these people who have every right
to act like a diva
um just don't and they're such team
players and
they make all the cast and crew just
feel so
excited to work on the project i love
hearing that
thank you i'm curious what do you find
more difficult
playing someone a little more reserved
like nick here or
you know maybe going a lot bigger with a
character like someone like billy and
stranger things
uh i feel like for me the only way that
i'm able to do it is to find
similarities in in a character i'm
playing so finding similarities in billy
finding similarities in nick
that's the only way i'm sort of able to
level for it
i don't think it's ever easy to do like
any of the stuff i feel like
it's easy to rock up on time and work
really hard which is all that i aim to
do and hopefully if i'm able to create a
good character then
i'm lucky so yeah it's surprising to
hear that from you after so many shows
and films at this point is
is there any specific thing that you do
on set where you're like
like that's my comfort zone i don't even
have to think about it i just get into
it
i'm always nervous like always i
just yeah i can't it's one of the big
reasons i can't do that because i just
yeah i i i just i suffer really badly
from nerves
on every anything anywhere red carp like
whatever it be
um but i definitely know that
feeling in myself when i feel like i
have relaxed enough in a character and
i'm kind of like in my head going okay
i'm i'm on the right track for myself
even if it's not the right track with
the director or the audience or so on
i'm always kind of trying to look for
that and i've i really only had that one
moment
where in my career where i walked on set
and i was like
i deserve to be here every other moment
i kind of have this self-depres
like this kind of like thing of like i
don't deserve to be here there's
50 000 people that want it behind me and
that's what i think drives me to work
harder because i'm like well if i'm here
and i'm not good enough i might as well
work 50 000 times harder than those
people behind me
and i think that's all that i can strive
for what is that one
one moment uh strange things season
three the sauna
scene we shot over a whole week with
sean levy
and uh and i just put everything i had
into it and i think it was the first
time i walked on set and went
i'm gonna [ __ ] own the [ __ ] out of
this
and and i and i think it was it was a
liberating moment
but also just always reminding myself to
keep working hard and
be extremely appreciative of the
opportunities i'm given
i like hearing that but i'm also a big
believer that those nerves come from
deeply caring about your craft so hold
on to them
yeah thanks barry of course so
i know this movie is about letting
things go but as
someone who really likes collecting
movie props i was wondering have you two
kept anything from the shows and the
movies that you've done over the years
yeah i'll let you outing yeah i
i feel like i've kept something from
everything
a lot of time clothes i've i've actually
kept a couple of lucy's
of lucy's dresses um you should
as i i tried really hard because she was
like no
yeah um so but i also took
the uh in nyx hotel room there's this
when i'm like this is hipster narnia and
then we walk through the little tunnel
there's this boxing robe hanging and and
i got to keep that it says champion on
the back
and it feels very the the broken hearts
hotel
solid hall right there what about you
um yeah i've uh so i've only done a
couple of things that i've i've said
it's total competence today so i've got
it down pat
power rangers i kept a piece of the
obsidian rock wall where we find the
coins the power coins
strange thing season two i kept my
jacket
and strange thing season three i kept a
pack of malba reds that lived in my
breast pocket
and on broken hearts i kept mix bracelet
so those are my
those are my tokens on the very few
things i've been lucky enough to work on
that i've
literally stolen but no one's come
asking questions i respect
those prices i might have a power coin
myself ah
very good i i wanted that thing and i
was gonna get it
oh yeah that's amazing